eu começo uma pergunta o que é
felicidade globos e complexa né
é uma resposta que é uma pergunta não
tem resposta porque quando a gente fala
de felicidade
a gente está lidando com um sentimento
de tristeza e alegria que são
transitórios
a gente não tem nem o domínio sobre eles
eles acontecem e na maioria das vezes a
gente não sabe como lidar com a questão
que existem algumas ações que a gente
pode se tornar para realizar para
modificar a perspectiva que essas
sentimentos o tempo sobre a nossa vida e
é isso que eu quero colocar um pouquinho
a gente conversar hoje é esse sentimento
tite dessa questão da felicidade quando
a gente consegue perceber uma definição
própria
essa definição de felicidade acaba
refletindo a definição que a gente tem
para nós mesmos de sucesso o que é
sucesso
eu não tenho pretensão de forma a chegar
aqui e dizer olha gente sucesso decisão
cinco passos e faz isso com ser feliz
não essa ideia porque não existe uma
fórmula não existe um passo a passo que
de olha para você ser feliz você vai ser
assim essa não existe mas a gente pode
olhar para essa é a nossa definição de
sucesso que a gente sonhou para a gente
perceber o que a gente pode transformar
de como a gente pode lidar com essas
expectativas
é eu percebo que quando a gente pensa
para nós mesmos como tendo sucesso está
diretamente ligado à corrente líquida
bandas de sonhos e expectativas
o jeito da gente trabalha essa relação
dentro da gente vai definir na frente
quando olhar envolveria antigo sucesso
obtido sucesso é inevitável pensar
quando eu lido com essas questões de
equilíbrio dentro de mim eu tô
diretamente pensando a maneira como eu
trabalho como eu me relaciono com minha
família como eu lido com todas as suas
esferas que estão entre os europeus que
fazem parte de mim e essa maneira de
buscar esse equilíbrio que vai me dar a
minha estrutura para me manter como
alcançando o amor que eu entrei com
sucesso
[Música]
minha família está ali atrás e tem dois
motivos pelo qual mostrando pra vocês a
foto agora o primeiro é que ninguém pode
negar que são as duas crianças mais
velhas no huoc
o segundo ponto é que esse é o motivo
pelo qual eu tenho um dispêndio de boa
parte do meu tempo nos últimos anos que
nem pensando a forma com que eu lido com
as minhas expectativas de vida familiar
de carreira
quando a gente casou em 2008 ele toy é é
a gente não sonharam filhos
a gente sabia que ele queria ter filhos
e em 2012 quando a gente olhou o que a
gente queria mudar algumas coisas
a família eu tranquei a faculdade ocorre
a trabalhar em casa e nós tomamos muitos
o desafio de vamos despendem de tempo
integral para ficar com ele nessa
primeira infância
e foi assim para o e mail não ficou
entre nada com a gente tudo bem o ano e
meio passou e eu precisava voltar para a
faculdade porque se eu votasse possível
e vamos achar uma escola seja boa a
gente consiga lidar com estrutura de eu
vou para a aula e ficam lá os dias em um
tribunal ele fica em casa comigo aqui
tudo foi muito bem e fizemos a adaptação
de um mês antes de eu voltar para a sala
de aula a gente viu os nossos planos de
queimar o café
essa experiência nos trouxe algumas
coisas muito interessantes que nada o
nosso processo de perceber as
necessidades de integração entre família
e trabalho
alguns profissionais nos trouxe muitos
muitos questionamentos
acontece nós não de maneira nenhuma nós
demonizamos as escolas
nós entendemos e assumimos a importância
que a escola tem na vida
a tese não foi porque uma coisa assim
acontecer com a gente que a gente vai às
ruas não escolhe 10 milhões o que nos
levou a perceber o quanto aquele momento
a nossa família colocaram numa escola
seria traumático seria é ferir o que a
gente sonhava as perspectivas de
vivências familiares para ele naquela
primeira infância
e aí a gente olhou somos um casal dois
profissionais e uma criança que não pode
pra escola que fazer o cultivo como faz
o que faz com que ser lida tendo
trabalhado em que faculdade para tudo
para tudo
vamos repensar ou pensar como faz
eu pergunto vocês como faz pra você
manter o protagonismo de cuidar dos seus
filhos que você quer que você sonhou e
ao mesmo tempo sem que as duas coisas se
conflitam você mantém a sua carreira
mas os estudos de uma maneira integral e
suficientemente sucede pra você
quando ele percebeu esse dilema
a gente começou a conversar com muita
gente ice amigo enfim o discurso de que
não era uma dor só nossa mas uma coisa
assim só aconteceu com a gente uma
decisão de pessoas que a gente teve
contato com isso aconteceu comigo também
eu também
essa percepção eu quero outras coisas e
quais vão perceber que de fato existe
uma geração
existe uma nova fase onde as pessoas
estão olhando por seus formatos mais
trabalho então selecionado será que este
formato que eu adotei hoje é o mais
adequado porque eu quero porque eu tenho
como perspectiva de liga
a gente começou a pesquisar e filme
existe existe uma geração que está
repensando os novos formatos que quer
outras opções
[Música]
esse recibo ainda quando a gente pensa
no contexto histórico dessa pressão a
gente pode perceber em que ao longo de
todo o século 20
os papéis no mercado de trabalho nos
contextos produtivos e reprodutivos
minha família e carreira eram muito
definidos pelos contextos dos papéis de
gênero o homem o papel do gênero homem
saía trabalhava trazia dentro da casa a
mulher
o gênero feminino da família nas
empresas praticamente inexistente
era a pessoa ficava em casa cuidando dos
filhos esse perfil não nos compreende
mais
hoje a gente tem um público onde as
mulheres também são praticava trabalhar
e é o mesmo tanto o sonho de também
ficam por que os homens também interessa
a cidade está em casa estavam
participando dessa rotina e não tem mais
fácil você tem um mulheres que para
cumprirem com esse perfil idealizado de
supermulheres supermães super
profissionais do ano acabam adotando
duplas triplas
nada de trabalho são mulheres se frustra
porque estamos em processo de sobrecarga
e homens jovens frustrados por não terem
a oportunidade diante do próprio
trabalho dizem os comerciantes também
interessa sim
isso é um contexto que nenhum dano ea
gente pode perceber em que estamos
vivendo um momento histórico onde de
fato os qualquer sociais estão mudando e
aí nós temos que parar e perceber o
quanto o quanto é essas mudanças de
perfil tão influenciado nos contextos de
trabalho
isso tem causado grandes fraturas nas
organizações porque esse processo
conturbado do equilíbrio em família
errei mas cobra preços altíssimos todos
os vasos
nós temos um preço caro cobrado das
mulheres que adotam esse veio nessa
jornada complicada dupla tripla
nós temos um preço emocional e
desenvolvimento organizacional dos
homens que têm dificuldade de lidar com
essa relação
nós temos hoje não só de crianças que
estão sendo criadas sem terem o perfil
masculino na vivência do dia a dia
porque isso é tirado de contexto
o homem não tá com o pai não tá com um é
como o papel masculino nessa na criação
dessa criança e isso traz é uma série de
de questões de desenvolvimento e isso
cobra trecho de volta não só não é só um
preço para a família
não são só as pessoas que pagam as
organizações paga você tem empresas que
muitos momentos da vida da história da
empresa são proforma de comprometidas
porque os seus funcionários têm questões
familiares que influenciam diretamente
no seu bem
o desempenho o nosso desempenho
profissional está diretamente ligado à
minha capacidade de equilibrar nas
minhas questões semanas familiares é é
uma fraude muito comum nessa disputa
vida profissional não se mistura com
vida pessoal
somos uma demanda de grande de
profissionais depois eu sou a mesma
profissional somente estudante que cuida
do vídeo que faz o almoço que respondem
meio do meu chefe que tenham
compromissos
eu sou mais absurdo como que não há
mistura vida profissional e ainda não
existe
nós somos pessoas complexas nós temos
demandas complexas isso as nossas férias
na disney não podem escolher de que
forma elas precisam se complementar e
como trabalha o tema de relações
sustentáveis né eu tenho certeza que na
primeira hora você vê
pensar em questões ambientais do meio
ambiente a natureza das relações
sustentáveis o que o torna o desafio é
que a gente olha me engano sustentável
uma definição mais ampla onde de fato a
gente precisa ter relações interpessoais
que se sustenta
elas precisam se sustentar a minha vida
profissional precisa sustentar e ser
sustentada pela minha família pela minha
vida pessoal porque senão nós vamos ter
e mega sucessos mega imagem de sucesso
profissional corrompidos por que eu abri
mão e eu optei por um tutor roubei
alguns são muito mais profundos que a
gente tem que ser nosso relacionamento e
familiares
isso gera frustração enquanto é eu
consigo perceber o quanto isso é
importante
e olhar para esse desafio me falaram que
eu preciso desenvolver uma forma de
equilibrar isso deixou meu contexto o
sucesso no equilíbrio desses processos
michel perin bandas de harmonia na minha
vida que não reflete diretamente na
harmonia e eu vou transmitir em meu
trabalho ele espécie então as relações
sustentáveis entre família e carreira é
exatamente isso tv que os processos não
são conflitantes
eles precisam se se autossustentar uma
coisa ligada a outra elas não podem se
conferisse e combaterei elas não podem
consumir
ela sempre se potencializar então o
termo sustentável é esta desse desafio
de pensar precisamos de algo novo que me
dê condições
o mundo do trabalho onde não precisa ser
uma pessoa frustrada porque abrir mão de
coisas que uma verdade eu queria abrir
mão
o mundo corporativo e as empresas e nós
como profissionais que são então desafio
primeiramente nosso prato depois disso
reflita nas nossas organizações é que a
gente aprender a educar o olhar e
entender que ela somente absolutamente
normal um homem executivo segurar uma
criança enquanto atende o telefone é
absolutamente normal uma mãe da
recém-nascida voltar ao mercado de
trabalho e ser compreendida como uma
pessoa que ainda tem as mesmas
competências que ela tinha antes do bem
e hoje mas o processo de materiais
processos de paternidade e desenvolve
competências que você não tinha então
essa esse processo de constituição a
única de família de volta no mercado de
trabalho profissionais mais abastados do
que aqueles antigos animais
hoje existem profissionais que tenham
visão de futuro o futuro
quem são as pessoas que mais têm a
percepção de futuro mãe bate na porta
todo dia de manhã os países têm essa
percepção
o detido de paternidade maternidade taxa
uma pessoa
isso precisa ser valorizado por nós no
ritz-carlton sensacionais que não é
porque é uma mulher perdeu o bebê por
rádio que se tornou pai dele magicamente
deixou de ser afetivo e viciante viu a
mulher não deixou de ser porque a tabela
é frágil é mansinho
ela só pensa em se beber não não é isso
nossas organizações precisam adaptadas
para que pense um pouquinho então tudo
bem
aquilo ficou doente ou em trânsito agora
tudo certo ele não vai deixar de ser
competente por causa disso não vai o meu
desafio pra vocês é que a gente comece a
pensar que o quanto nós estamos correndo
atrás de uma idéia de sucesso
profissional que vai nos cobrar um preço
muito alto na frente é uma organização
de um super profissional que não tem
vida
isso não é isso a gente tem é o quanto a
gente está correndo atrás de construir
um mundo maravilhoso uma estrutura
fantástica para as nossas crianças
nossos filhos dessa geração que estava
em mas antes de tudo a gente precisa
parar de pensar o quanto nós estamos
trabalhando para construir pessoas
melhores
[Aplausos]